et je les dis une page politique la
fédération ump des yvelines vient de
délivrer ses premières investitures pour
les municipales sans surprise aurore
bergé a été par exemple confirmé à magny
les hameaux amour pas la situation est
plus complexe on va en parler dans
quelques instants avec mon invité
grégory caret ce qui est tout d'abord ce
reportage
les premières investitures de l'ump pour
les municipales de mars 2014 ont été
connus ce lundi soir elle concerne tout
d'abord les communes qui ne sont pas
détenues par la droite dans le
département
ainsi sur le secteur de saint quentin en
yvelines aurore bergé a été confirmée à
magny les hameaux
ladislas cura à guyancourt pour ce qui
concerne les villes de trappes et de la
verrière les investitures ne seront pas
connus avant l'automne à bois d'arcy
c'est philippe benassaya directeur de la
communication à la mairie d'elancourt
qui a été choisi pour faire basculer la
commune actuellement menée par le
socialiste claude juillet pour mort pas
la situation n'est pas tranchée grégory
gare et ce qui a été confirmé comme chef
de file de l'ump dans la commune mais
l'investiture n'a pas encore été
officiellement donnée dans l'attende un
accord local avec lui des i lui dénie à
maurepas est représentée par pierre
leguérinel premier maire adjoint et qui
assure actuellement l'intérim en
l'absence pour raison médicale du maire
divers gauche georges mougeot grégory
guerre et astier et pierre leguérinel
n'ont pas caché leur souhait d'être tête
de liste en mars prochain
enfin le comité départemental s'est
également penché sur l'investiture ump
dans le cadre de la cantonale partielle
de menthe dont le premier tour est ce
dimanche 30 juin elle a été accordé sans
surprise à pierre bédier
l'ancien président du conseil général en
alerte face à la têt maintenant sur les
municipales à maurepas et notamment la
position de la droite gagne rien
vestiaires bonsoir l'ump des yvelines a
donné ses investitures pour les
prochaines municipales dans les communes
c'est première investiture en tout cas
pour les communes qui ne sont pas
détenues par la droite
vous n'avez pas été officiellement
investi par l'ump vous êtes déçu non pas
du tout c'est pas encore comme cela que
ça fonctionne au sein du comité
départemental
il ya plusieurs étapes la première étape
s'est déroulée c'était en mai dernier
au comité départemental de rambouillet
où il y a il a été acté et décider de
liste la liste ump que je représenterai
liste udi et hier soir à maisons
laffitte à la réunion auquel j'étais
convié où j'ai pu m'exprimer de plus
devant plus de 200 élus j'ai été investi
officiellement chef de file ump pour les
élections municipales et donc à ce titre
je représenterai en tant que tête de
liste ump aux élections municipales le
premier a été désigné comme chef chef de
file chef de file est en tout cas moi je
suis candidat déclaré irresponsable de
l'ump ne mord pas donc je serai candidat
ump au premier tour pour vous c'est donc
un premier pas oui bien sûr puis ce sera
entérinée ensuite au mois de septembre
c'est le processus décisionnel dans ce
cas de figure
en tout cas le communiqué de presse de
la fédération précise que la décision
sera prise dans l'attenté d'un accord
local avec le dernier alors lui dit sur
mon repas c'est notamment pierre
leguérinel qu'il incarne en ce moment
puisqu'il est premier maire adjoint et
les met en tout cas par intérim en
remplacement de georges mougeot lui il
n'a pas caché il veut être tête de liste
aussi aux prochaines municipales alors
comment ça va se passer
est-ce que déjà vous avez des vous avez
déjà vu des rapports des rapprochements
avec alors non nous ne sommes pas encore
rencontrée alors évidemment la situation
du premier adjoint de la ville de
maurepas est très compliquée puisque lui
dit
par la force des choses et est divisée
au sein de donc de la ville de mort
parce que le premier adjoint est en tout
cas le garant de la majorité socialiste
de maurepas avec laquelle il a fait un
accord en 2008 et donc à ce titre alors
que lui et des ihu niveau national est
avec jean louis borloo dans l'opposition
au gouvernement héros évidemment ça pose
quelques problèmes au niveau local donc
on ne comprend pas très bien
absolument alors là il n'y a pas non
plus mari n'est pas marginalisés au sein
de 100 pages et oui bien sûr alors c'est
une position peut-être qu'il devra
clarifier dans l'est dans les semaines
ou les mois qui viennent en tout cas de
mon côté à l'ump en tant que responsable
ump je je je mène une équipe une liste
qui est unie et rassemblée alors que la
majorité actuelle est vraiment très
divisée
puisqu'on va s'attendre au moins à trop
quatre candidats ou moins qu'à vous
souhaiter monnaies nist aller jusqu'au
bout bien sûr bien sûr il jamais à
l'automne l'ump ne vous investit pas et
investi un autre candidat en
l'occurrence pierre bouquet final qu'est
ce qu'est ce que vous ferez ce que vous
irez quand même alors havre est déjà un
oui j'irai jusqu'au bout et 2 je ne
pense pas que les investitures seront
données en ce sens en tout cas c'est pas
le le signe qui a été donné en tout cas
hier soir
et puis je le rappelle moi je suis le
responsable de l'opposition
donc le projet actuel de la majorité
c'est celui qui ne me convient pas et
c'est celui que je ne partage pas et
donc moi je suis le candidat de
l'alternance c'est à dire que les
mauraciens s'ils souhaitent autre chose
pour nos repas un autre avenir pour la
ville je suis le candidat qui leur faut
et dont je suis le candidat qui va
représenter le renouvellement et de
l'alternance le candidat de la droite
est donc naturellement tout ce qui a été
voté au sein de la majorité pendant ces
six ans en grande majorité sur les
grands projets je ne suis pas d'accord
et donc à partir de là chacun devra en
prendre les les conclusions qui
s'imposent
je rappelle un côté inverse élections
municipales il y avait quatre listes
absolument il ya eu donc deux tours pour
départager georges mougeot et et nicole
malaquais qui était la candidate ump sur
ce nouveau l'avait emporté avec un peu
plus de 500 poussins s'en voit sa
sanction 17 saaba vous savez les députés
500 voix d'écart en ayant constitué
justement une liste d'alliance avec
pierre le guennec qui à l'époque avait
l'étiquette modem c'est compliqué un
report à ce poids là pour arriver à
trouver une ligne claire alors c'est
compliqué ces vagues 2008 a quand même
laissé beaucoup de traces
hees a encore laissé beaucoup de traces
dans l'électorat de droite parce que je
vais beaucoup de rencontres est mort
passe bien en ce moment et lele mora
gens n'ont pas oublié 2008 était
particulière parce qu'il ya eu justement
le parachutage de monsieur via une aile
qui était de montigny-le-bretonneux qui
avaient été investis contre toute
attente contre madame malaquin que
j'avais soutenu à l'époque est donc
naturellement ça a laissé des traces
d'autant plus que la liant ce second
tour n'a pas pu se faire et que le
premier adjoint puisqu'il a refusé de
faire une alliance avec nous et qu'il
préférait aller avec le parti socialiste
donc là aussi ça a laissé pas mal de sa
peur que l'histoire se répète
non parce que là le cas de figure est
différent comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la droite est unie et rassemblée
je suis dans l'opposition donc
clairement dans le coup
ici on est donc
j'ai fait signe d'une attaque la droite
représentée par la droite représentée
par l'ump absolument au sein du conseil
municipal municipal et puis au delà
également et puis du coup bah c'est pour
ce qui est de la majorité municipale
actuelle ça veut dire pas d'accord et
claudie n'ont pas forcément pas
forcément en tout cas au premier tour a
pas d'accord car nous donne au premier
au premier tour il faut qu'on en discute
mais ça va être ça va être très
compliqué par rapport à sa position moi
j'attends qu'il se positionne par
rapport aussi à l'ump c'est assez inédit
comme situation comme je le dis souvent
maurepas est un cas d' un cas d'école
politiques ou même un objet de science
politique qu'on pourrait être un autre
cas d'école aussi étonnant c'est que
vous avez lancé le club mort pas
d'absolu 14 tableaux en novembre 2007
chez mclaren où vous souhaitez quand
vous souhaitiez assez peuvent déjà être
candidat aux municipales à man party
vraiment au moins deux mondial est-il ah
oui c'est ça fait six ans et vous êtes
jeunes bien sûr depuis longtemps et dans
ce club maurepas 2014 il y a pas remis à
les cinq membres fondateurs du club
harman le gall qui est responsable du
parti radical et des amours pas
absolument on comprend plus rien bon bah
écoutez si les choses sont claires
au contraire monsieur le gall que je
remercie d'ailleurs de son soutien qui
fait un excellent travail sur maurepas
et dont j'ai besoin de ses compétences
pour mener une liste pluraliste pour le
premier tour est clairement dans
l'opposition avec moi donc lui d y est
clairement dans l'opposition aussi au
niveau national donc les choses sont
claires de notre côté mais malgré tout
dimanche soir lui des départementales a
déclaré qu'il n'y aurait pas de candidat
udi sur une issue mt à mort par écouter
insinue t on et a acté sa part marc
gales par exemple qui vous soutient
depuis novembre 2000 douze ans que de
maurepas 2014 n'aurait pas sa place sur
votre liste
si justement il faut qu' il rejoint en
tout cas l'ump parce que lui des hits un
allié naturel
après je regrette par rapport à
l'information vous me donnez que je que
je ne connaissais pas que lui dire au
fuse que lier d'autres udi sur d'autres
listes parce que moi-même j'accueille
sur ma liste en tant que responsable ump
de maurepas et chef de file des jus d y
donc quand on a vocation à rassembler il
ne faut pas se couper en tout cas de
toutes les compétences vous avez déjà
constitué votre liste en tout cas déjà
en grande partie pour
comme je vous disais vous vous êtes
lancé oui ça fait six ans que je me
prépare et donc j'ai eu le temps de
réfléchir beaucoup à cette question est
en effet si par exemple l'élection avec
lui demain oui la liste serait constitué
après une liste il faut pas la fermer
tout de suite au gré des rencontres que
je vais faire avec mon équipe
pendant cette campagne il faut la
laisser ouverte à tous les talents et
toutes les compétences pour pouvoir
proposer un projet moment pas bien et
c'est ça qui est important
vous dit mords pas être un cas d'école
je reviens sur un autre cas d'école
c'était cantonales de mars 2008 le
canton ne mord pas coignières a été
remporté par un socialiste is mallavan
dans le cadre d'une triangulaire
oui entre deux jeunes ont souvent une
paix en rit pas yeux et gerald de favier
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur que ce
scénario se reproduise nous non parce
que c'était différent
en 2008 c'était deux candidats ump qui
était au second tour là on a je suis le
responsable ump ne mens pas je donc je
suis le reste correspondant le chef de
file de l'ump qui mènera cette liste et
puis ensuite on a une espèce de liste un
peu bizarre je dirai où on a des udi qui
sont avec les socialistes et puis des
u10 qui seront avec moi ça c'est le
problème du midi c'est pas mon problème
moi je suis à l'ump que l'idée y règle
ses problèmes avec avec ses instances
et puis après on verra bien chacun
défendra son projet et vous savez un
premier tour c'est c'est une campagne de
combat on affirme son projet sa propre
et clips et ses valeurs c'est surtout ça
qui est important c'est propre valeur
avec une éthique et une morale premier
tour ça peut être comme un primaire à
droite droite 130 je dirai pas ce mot là
parce qu'une primaire s'étendait entre
des candidats qui sont de la même
famille là c'est pas le cas
et ensuite le second tour il a vocation
à rassembler plus largement que le
premier tour et donc là naturellement il
faudra discuter
vous allez être entraînements oui vous
avez déclaré dans les nouvelles de
versailles l'hebdomadaire que ma
jeunesse c'est mieux portante
qu'est ce que vous a motivée en
politique tout avait un mentor
départementale
non j'ai pas de jets pas de mentors
politiques particuliers ça fait depuis
l'âge de 16 ans je suis en politique je
suis adhérent de l'ump depuis sa
création
donc je suis un homme politique de
droite et puis je suis mort patients de
naissance c'est donc au delà des
étiquettes politiques je fais vraiment
les choses avec le coeur avec tout ce
que j'ai dans le ventre et j'ai vraiment
envie de devenir le prochain maire de
desmaures passe bien mais la ville
depuis 89 vous faire penser à la
victoire alors premièrement il ya le
levant nationale qui n'est pas favorable
à la majorité actuelle
et puis deuxièmement ce sera à l'envi de
renouvellement je fais beaucoup de porte
à porte en ce moment je vais rencontrer
beaucoup de mort passe bien et les gens
vraiment envie de renouvellement et je
l'incarnent déjà par le par ma personne
parce que je suis un jeune candidat
également et parce que j'ai une équipe
renouvelée dynamique et j'incarne cet
espoir d'un notre avenir
moi je vous demander votre mentor en
politique je pense à vous allez me
répondre jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt parce que vous êtes chargé
de communication à la ville d'elancourt
et que philippe benassaya qu'est le
directeur de communication de la ville
d'elancourt et lui a été investi pour le
kite investiguant mais même si j'aime
tes un simple oui peut-être l'ump à bois
d'arcy
vous êtes content pour votre wii vont
changer
cce est en cours est une terre pour le
fruit du hasard parce que moi même ça
fait des années que je dis que je serai
candidat de toute façon cette élection
puis si vous voulez qu'on reparle de
philips est un excellent candidat pour
pour la ville de banda ainsi je suis
certain qu'il fera un excellent maire
d'arcis menée pour le moment par un
socialiste claude vieillesse merci la
grille aurait garanti merci à vous j'ai
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau 17